c'est un thème qui à l'échelon mondial
devient un vrai souci général cette idée
d'inégalité c'est l'idée avant tout que
euh les êtres humains sont égaux euh en
droit dans la plupart des des pays
développés mais dans la réalité des
faits sociaux euh selon euh son lieu de
naissance selon sa catégorie sociale de
naissance selon les ressources de ses
parents selon ses capacités de travail
son état de santé ainsi de suite les les
destins divergent et en fait ce qui est
extrêmement inquiétant sur cette
question question des inégalités c'est
que nous avons tous vécu dans l'idée que
l'égalisation des conditions de vie et
la progression des niveau de vie c'est
l'image même du progrès social depuis
des décennies en fait à l'échelon
mondial ce que nous mesurons dans le
monde en Europe mais ce qu'on mesure
aussi en France c'est le fait que notre
avenir ressemble de moins en moins à ce
qui était l'avenir normal des années
1970 c'est-à-dire dans les années 70 la
progression des salaires la progression
des niveaux de vie la progression de la
protection sociale de l'étatpridence
était la marche normale des sociétés
européennes dans un contexte où les plus
pauvres rattrapaient beaucoup plus vite
que ne progressaient les les plus riches
cette situation là s'est arrêtée voilà
une trentaine d'années déjà c'est-à-dire
nous sommes au bout d'une génération qui
a connu une forte stagnation sociale et
maintenant nous assistons à une forme
d'inversion qui ne fait que débuter en
France c'est-à-dire j'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises c'est un phénomène mondial
Trump a été élu dans un contexte de
déstabilisation profonde des classes
moyennes et des classes populaires
américaines où les salaires ne
permettent plus de vivre décemment dans
la société de consommation américaine
pour 2 tiers de la population c'est la
même chose en France nous sommes au
début en France la situation n'est pas
aussi critique voire apocalyptique
qu'elle ne l'est aux États-Unis en
France en revanche nous commençons avoir
une grande
progression en fait le dans le phénomène
français qui est intéressant c'est la
stagnation des ressources dans un
contexte où les inégalités ont cessé de
se réduire ce qui signifie que pour les
catégories cessé de se réduire mais on
le voit dans dans le rapport he pardon
de l'Observatoire des inégalités aussi
que les inégalités de revenus ça
croissent aussi par le bas en France
c'est une c'est un accroissement par le
bas c'est un accroissement qui est lié
notamment au fait que nagerre dans les
années 70 le bas vivait de salaire
modeste mais qu'aujourd'hui une partie
importante des revenus les plus faibles
dépendent avant tout de redistribution
publique qui aujourd'hui sont de plus en
plus mises sous pression c'est-à-dire
que nous avons une une situation où
nagerre les pauvres étaient relativement
autonome par leur PROE propre salaire
modeste dans dans leur situation et que
maintenant ils sont beaucoup plus
dépendants d'un État providence de plus
en plus chancelant ce qui se passe en
plus c'est que en raison de ce processus
de de plus de 30 ans de stagnation des
conditions de vie dans les catégories
populaires en France les familles qui
étaient un amortisseur depuis 30 ans les
familles ont permis de de de de réduire
le choc de la crise économique pour les
jeunes générations les familles
progressivement n'en peuvent plus
c'est-à-dire que en fait voilà 30 ans
les jeunes de 20 ans avaient des des des
parents qui avaient eu plus d'occasion
d'accumuler de l'épargne de devenir
propriétaire de leur maison aujourd'hui
les jeunes de 20 ans dépendent de plus
de de de parents d'une cinquantaine
d'années de plus en plus en en
difficulté ce qui signifie que les
différents amortisseurs des chocs que
l'on avait dont on avait bien bénéficié
au cours des années récentes plus
d'amortisseurs des choc puisque dans
Rapp du modèle social français qui a
permis
justement l'État providence est de plus
en plus en difficulté pour tout un
ensemble de de raisons est-ce que l'on a
appelé à une époque la famille
Providence c'est-à-dire les
grands-parents et les parents capable
d'amortir les les les chocs pour leurs
enfants chômeurs la situation devient de
plus en plus difficile ce qu'on mesure
en plus et c'est un
phénomène sinon nouveau mais qui par
accumulation du
temps le reportage le reportage disait
qu'il n'y avait rien de nouveau mais ce
qui est nouveau c'est le fait que à
mesure d'accumuler les décennies de
ralentissement et les contextes
difficiles on commence à avir de à voir
le bout des des des crises passion
sociales et l'un des éléments de crise
passation majeure aujourd'hui c'est le
patrimoine c'est le logement c'est la
propriété du logement c'est le
surendettement d'un grand nombre de
famille de travailleurs de 40 à 55 ans
un peu avant un peu après et en fait
l'expansion la montée en puissance des
prix du logement la multiplication par
deux du prix du mètre carré dans la
plupart des des régions françaises des
grandes villes de région française et
pire encore à Paris où la la la la la
croissance du prix du mètre carré
continue d'augmenter cela disqualifie
les niveaux de vie des salariés modestes
et maintenant des salariés des classes
moyennes qui peuvent voir effectivement
en terme absolu que leur salaire est
correct mais retraduit en prix du
logement en prix du mètre carré un
salaire même très bon dans Paris
intramuros devient de plus en plus
difficile pour accéder au au logement
décent mais pourquoi les politiques
publiques finalement échouent à résorber
ses écarts on sait qu'en 2012 François
Hollande c'était celui justement qui
portait le peut-être le plus cette
couleur de l'égalité 5 ans après les
déceptions sont immenses les déceptions
sont effectivement immense mais il
existe une une réalité tangible qui est
que tant que la machine économique
française ne repartira pas sur le
fondement avant tout du du travail qu'il
soit salarié ou indépendant permettant
de rapporter vraiment un niveau de vie
supplémentaire pour pour la population
on ne pourra
pasri pour voilà on pourra pas
redistribuer certainement réforme du
Code du travail mais c'est aussi ce sont
aussi des investissements c'est-à-dire
que avant de dépenser de redistribuer
l'argent quel que soit le secteur de
redistribution qu'il s'agisse de la
santé ou de l'école voire des retraites
ou de toute autre nature de
redistribution pour redistribuer il faut
d'abord que cet argent existe quelque
part la machine économique allemande ou
des pays nordiques et quand même
considérablement reparti au cours des 10
dernières années donc vous voyez des
éléments dans le programme d'Emmanuel
Macron qui vont permettre justement de
réaliser ses investissements de relancer
la machine sur le modèle économique
allemand selon vous euh disons qu'il a
fait une partie de son programme sur
cette question là il reste que il faut
lui souhaiter beaucoup de courage à
partir de de de maintenant parce qu'il
va falloir passer des paroles à leur
mise en application dans le contexte
d'une société française extrêmement
tendue où il ne suffira pas de dire mais
en même temps il va falloir maintenant
agir et c'est vrai que on ne sait jamais
s'il est beau parleur sont toujours de
bonnes personnes pour l'action politique
d'implémentation directe des de réformes
urgentes de façon à relancer la machine
économique ce ne sont pas que des
réformes du Code du travail c'est la
capacité à retrouver des marges
d'investissement pour sortir
l'université pour sortir l'éducation
pour ressortir la ville dans son de son
état de marasme actuel mais aussi pour
ressortir l'entreprise privée dans sa
capacité de production de biens et de
services nouveaux et de de distri parz
de l'éducation Louis Chauvel on a
souvent parlé de l'école comme une
machine justement à favoriser à
reproduire les inégalités est-ce qu'on
va enfin en sortir aussi de ce phénomène
je répète la question de
l'investissement est vital dès que l'on
visite un petit peu des pays étrangers
pas simplement les États-Unis où on est
dans dans le cadre d'unun voilà des
bourses enfin des des des des tution and
fees des frais de scolarité à 50000
dollars par an comme à Colombia
University à New York c'est pas
forcément ce qu'on souhaite
immédiatement à la société française
mais sans parler de ces cas extrêmes les
pays nordiques l'Allemagne et tout un
ensemble de de de pays dans cette
direction
là l'autrich aussi ont des systèmes
universitaires d'excellence et de masse
alors que le problème de fond en France
c'est le fait que l'université a été
considérablement poupérisée dans une
spirale du déclassement de de de de la
pauvreté de masse qui fait que
effectivement investir dans l'école
c'est important mais il faut vraiment le
faire quand on compare l'université de
nanter par exemple à l'université de
yeborg en Suède et c'est pas le
capitalisme néolibéral qui règne à en
Suède on voit véritablement que la
France est en tr enin de prendre un
retard considérable dans les ressources
cognitives de connaissance de savoir et
de savoir-faire offert aux nouvelles
générations en France nous avons un bon
système de grande école mais
malheureusement il ne touche qu'un qu'un
tout petit pourcentage de la population
des jeunes étudiants français qui pour
la plupart vont partir à l'étranger
simplement parce que les salaires sont
meilleurs à l'étranger et surtout leur
capacité d'action est infini considérabl
considérablement supérieur et je ne
parle pas une fois encore que des
États-Unis je parle aussi du du Québec
beaucoup de jeunes ingénieurs français
ne peuvent pas
euh ne peuvent pas appliquer leur
savoir-faire en France ils vont donc à
Bombardier chez Bombardier au Québec
pour fabriquer des des des des rames
pour pour pour les métros français c'est
un côté un petit peu pathétique sans
investissement massif dans l'école dans
l'université mais aussi dans le vrai
travail euh privé dans le secteur privé
euh comme public euh la société
française ne redémarrera pas de ce point
de vue-là